hello my name is Raquel Vega and I'm a
scientist at thermo Fisher neurological
disorders are multifactorial in nature
but genetic factors play a major role
Carolina's genetic risk factor increases
the chances or suffering some form of
the disorder in this study we utilize
human induced pluripotent stem cells in
combination with CRISPR cut 9 to
generate isogenic cell lines that differ
only in the CRISPR editor gene
preserving the rest of the genome
identical between lines as a consequence
we were able to systematically evaluate
in a controlled manner the effects of
the gene modification in a number of
phenotypic assays amenable for drug
discovery efforts we bypass the
time-consuming process of cell
engineering by using a verb of disease
modeling workflow stem flex media in a
stable kasnian expressing human IPS a
line of apartment to introduce the
mutations as a result we obtain height
editing efficiencies in the cell post
generated which also had high rate of
survival after single cell sorting the
disease model workflow also included an
extensive characterization of the edited
IPS aligned to ever way the morphology
to verify they had normal karyotype and
to confirm they remain pluripotent after
the engineering process using the
ability of the IPS C to expand
indefinitely we were able to make a bank
of cryopreserve engineer line to
generate the disease lines we targeted
took well known disease genes the first
one called
disrupted in schizophrenia 1 this gene
also known as disc 1 has been associated
via genetic and molecular studies with
schizophrenia and bipolar disorders
the studies revealed that the loss of
the c-terminal of this corn protein
leads to inherited mental disorders to
generate a truncated disc one IPC line
we generated a 4 base-pair deletion in
exon 12 which resulted in a frameshift
mutation in as consequence a fit
terminal truncated protein we also
generate a vector recycled version where
one allele carry the truncated form in
the other allele remain unchanged
we also generated a mutation in the
calcium channel voltage-dependent l type
alpha 1 c subunit gene also known as
cognizance e carry in the variant G 406
are in one allele of this gene causes a
delay channel inactivation resulting in
elevation of intracellular calcium open
T polarization patients carrying this
mutation display severe nervous system
abnormalities including autism expectrum
disorder this condition is known as
tamati syndrome we engineer the 406 our
mutation in the TerraCycle storm to
generate the disease IPC line once we
obtain a genic pairs the heart identical
genetic background except for the design
rotation we fall on to mature in the IPC
lines to obtain mural progenitors ncns
derive neurons they as if we select to
use a high content so health gene
expression in calcium influx for this
coin I see any lines we perform a new
right length hike on Tennessee in data
shows that rotated this commutation
mutation has a generate this resulted in
Polish by various groups we observed
this one line under glucose patrol
elicited a stronger caspase activation
in high LDH levels relative to control
line the kin expression as
enable us to emit to confirm the absence
of the C terminal portion in the
truncated disc online and obtain
relative transcript levels of neural
markers involved progenitor and neurons
the calcium ion in flock assays results
showed a hyper polarized state in the
line carrying the dominant mutation
before all six are and we were able to
block such hyper response with the
l-type calcium channel inhibitor drug
memo tip in to summarize using this
robust disease modeling workflow enable
us to streamline the Isagenix align
generation obtain unlimited number OPC
self the support screening and perform
experiments under control settings thank
you very much for viewing or poster
you